desde el acuerdo de parís de 2015 el
objetivo sigue siendo el mismo para los
países firmantes limitar el
calentamiento global a 15 grados
centígrados para finales de siglo sin
embargo según la clasificación del grupo
de investigación climate action tracker
sólo un país cumple los criterios para
lograrlo cambia gracias a la
reforestación y la energía solar de este
pequeño país agrícola se acerca a su
objetivo de reducción de co2
detrás de gambia se encuentra una
potencia industrial el reino unido- que
recibe la mención casi suficiente una
puntuación basada principalmente en sus
promesas pero otra organización new
carbon brave confirma que el país
británico ya tiene un buen rendimiento
dado que el 11 está a medio camino de
alcanzar su objetivo de ser emisiones de
carbono para 2050
para un tracker marruecos costa rica y
etiopía también van por buen camino
según el mighty technology review
francia es el cuarto país más ecológico
del mundo pero estos buenos resultados
se basan principalmente en el gasto
invertido en una recuperación verde como
la producción de hidrógeno las emisiones
medidas de co2 en los sectores del
transporte y la agricultura son más
elevadas en francia que en la mayoría de
los países europeos según el lema
technology review los países que más se
han esforzado por reducir las emisiones
de gas son ucrania noruega y suecia tres
países cuyas políticas climáticas
globales aún se consideran insuficientes